hey shut the [ __ ] up Felix potat the
steaming active let's see how long I
will do this accent pity PI plays a game
what is this 27 5 act serum here we go
this is game about love drawing and only
drawing I don't know why I didn't love
in there maybe maybe there's a love in
there somewhere
click the easel to start painting what's
a neat oh that's an easel I did not know
that why I can draw whatever I want I
will draw slippy and it's perfect
rendering
this is what this game is about you just
draw that's awesome
why do I even bother this is so [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is alright it's done I
guess wait I can't - put it somewhere
here here
I don't all right there okay can someone
please buy this painting
Jeff hey what up dog you want to buy my
Jeff please buy it no we'll shove your
butt get up your ass boy yes I'll take
it I guess he liked Jeff huh I guess we
just draw another one is this what we're
gonna do this video just [ __ ] draw I
think by the shade of this you can
already tell the who I'm drawing there's
only one man in the world with this
beautiful skin complex and his name
rhymes with rump but I don't know okay
that's that's him
there you go why do I even bother we'll
call him rump there's anyone want to buy
Rob police but do when will this call
this video PewDiePie draws for a [ __ ]
hour Jesus Christ all right who else
should we draw I'm taking suggestions
you made a painting mate but you didn't
make it art synth since have you seen
your [ __ ] face cuz you look like [ __ ]
there you go finally someone who knows
pleasure doing business with you Abbi
dog all right speaking of dogs let's
draw this shitty meme that everyone is
obsessed with and I don't understand why
I honestly was not implant planning to
enjoy this game so much I was like why
are people playing this game all you do
is draw what's the [ __ ] point
yeah idiots you're all idiots and
meanwhile Here I am
well I'm pretty sure that if you chip
doesn't work out I can always become
just a street artist cuz god damn look
at this piece of art it makes me
emotional I'm having an emotional
episode right now this is so goddamn
beautiful I don't know where to begin I
did it I did it
it's my Mona Lisa it's my hot dog but a
hot dog hot dog everybody that's my name
hot dog hot dog every body there you go
and that will be Saul you [ __ ] poor
you best nut if you criticize my
everyday comments are quips used by the
privileged to keep others in their place
microaggressions accumulate Masoli today
literally kill yourself what does she
want from me what will make her
satisfying
now I know what triggered people feels
like cuz [ __ ] Jesus Christ
alright see if you can guess which one
I'm drawing now this is gonna be my new
Mona Lisa likes energy for scent how
about you take some cyanide okay have
you thought about that see how your
energy goes you [ __ ] [ __ ] you
[ __ ] [ __ ] sorry I might seem
aggressive but he frustrates me when
people say they know art yes you will
have it with your baguette take it
finally someone that understands and
appreciates
[Music]
yeahit's yes okay here we go sell it
look at that [ __ ] boy it's absolutely
stunning you [ __ ] what mate let's
sell it
hopefully [ __ ] cyanide [ __ ] will
appreciate it I guess I guess we just
keep drawing Steve why don't you leave
he did he did leave okay well whatever
likes energy I don't like it's doing
this for you Maggie
you spiked hair [ __ ] [ __ ] sorry I
get too emotional about my art some say
I can't take criticism I'll draw
something close to my heart then George
[ __ ] no one wants to buy it
beautiful piece of art why does no one
want my art colors too crazy literally
kill yourself Maggie I don't know why
you come here to spit at my work
she's such a mean person such a
mean-spirited person okay well let's try
this again literally stop stop okay I'm
trying my best here
[Music]
wait I change to spray but I don't want
spray what the [ __ ]
no I clicked it away by accident I'm
gonna have to sell ponder ahaab why sir
not a regret button why does my life not
have a regret button can someone answer
me that I'm gonna have to speed up now
otherwise I'm gonna run out of [ __ ]
business god damn it okay it's done and
it's beautiful okay can someone please
for the love of God buy this one or else
I'm going out of bass this skillfully
made you bet your [ __ ] sweet access
skillfully made what is this a scale me
alright bit higher
hell yeah mother [ __ ] hell yeah I'm the
king I'm the goddamn King this is gonna
be my Mona Lisa I know it
Sugoi - so do i so go ahead
how is you know yes I would buy that I
would definitely buy that hell yeah xxxx
Sugoi Tet Tassie on that one I will sell
for at least a couple of dollars this
one is personal I really hope that you
guys are gonna like this one common
comment along if you figure out what it
is chew on red hell yeah xx
Sugoi ASEAN is yours buddy I just
realize how incredibly obvious it is
what I'm drawing if I start it like this
have you guessed what I'm drawing yet no
well try again [ __ ]
boy hell yeah my name on it
front end in my college day [ __ ] yes I
can't ramp in no wonder [ __ ]
yes it's awesome I love it
he's so I would buy this art and I know
you would too
I'll call this one England is my city
beautiful this one is gonna go for a lot
I can tell I hate pink well then you
hate life because if you hate on this
art then you hate life itself
this man is God this man is God himself
you were born from this man you may not
know it but you are [ __ ] you George
this better be good shut up
what is he drawing I don't know this is
truly a beautiful this is going to
change laughs is it spongebob perhaps
the answer will shock you alrights
Michael from Vsauce
yeah no [ __ ] it I don't goddamn just
give me money just give me money at this
point
where's the energy made it so [ __ ] you
okay let's finish this off let's finish
this off with a good meme like good meme
everyone I'm sure you all recognize this
guy
[Music]
but wait a minute
it is not finished yet now that's a logo
type right there
fine I'll sell [ __ ] Vsauce cuz it's
so ugly there it is okay
alright I think I think it's time for me
to stop I am clearly addicted this is a
super fun game I really enjoy it no one
will buy my [ __ ] Nick Crompton I
don't get it
I don't get it what do I have to do here
what do I have to do here maybe change
name on it anyway if you enjoyed this
video please leave a thumbs up thank you
guys so much for watching I'll see you
tomorrow with another episode
another bad cuffs piece of [ __ ]